[Musique]
je n'ai ajar bonjour secrétaire général
du ppm et manquent de l'opposition et
prm à la 7e journée agen bonjour alain
bourgeois toute la matinée qui nous
écoutent
en tant qu'élu de la ctm est ce que vous
voulez est ce que vous êtes fier ce que
vous êtes fiers de vous après la
plénière d'hier je parle de tous les
élus de la majorité confondus s p les
élus martiniquais ont de quoi
aujourd'hui être fiers du tout et je
pense qu'il faut pas à parler de fiat
est aujourd'hui nous cherchons à ce que
la vérité soit dite hic le peuple sache
en toute transparence
en toute honnêteté la réalité de la
situation financière de la collectivité
territoriale de martinique
on s'y attelle avec des preuves à
l'appui et c'est surtout ça qui compte
parce qu'aujourd'hui le pays en
souffrance ce qui est à l'arrêt il faut
vraiment qu une dynamique de projets se
mettre en place avec de vrais
investissements
c'est sur cet enjeu là que nous sommes
tous aujourd'hui on a l'impression quand
même qu'il ya un an quand récurrent
depuis les élections de 2015 mais
écoutez c'est très facile vous leur
trouble et l'eau salée détruire c'est
facile construire c'est difficile nous
essayons d'apporter les preuves mais
vous voyez il limite les temps de parole
alors que les conseillers exécutifs ont
tout le loisir de s'exprimer
ils sont beaucoup plus nombreux que nous
donc on est pris en étau quelque part en
termes de prise de parole et
d'intervention mais nous arrivons à nous
exprimer c'est ça le plus important est
non seulement nous disons les éviter
mais nous avons les preuves de ce que
nous avançons contrairement à eux qui
annonce des chiffres mais que derrière
il n'y a aucun document qui reflète la
réalité de ce qui est dit sinon la
parole d'un homme ou d'un groupe ce que
vous pensez que les martiniquais
sincèrement ce qu'elle martiniquais
comprennent ce qui se passe à
l'assemblée lors d'une plénière
oui je peux comprendre que le trouble
qui jeté le doute qui le vif à ce
qu'aujourd'hui les gens ne comprennent
pas nécessairement mais il faut quand
même aujourd'hui rester concentré et
regarder la situation en face la santé
financière de la collectivité
territoriale la martinique est très
bonne et je parle à toutes les petits
chefs d'entreprise à toutes les
personnes qui en compte en banque qui
font une demande de prêt quand on tout
se permet de dire que la situation n'est
pas bonne
alors que les banques prêtent
109 millions duroux à la ctm 97 millions
d'euros en renégociation 112 millions de
prêts effectifs mobilisés mais non
dépassé et a dit qu'ils ont pris
l'argent et l'on met sur le compte
ils ne l'ont pas dépenser parce qu'ils
n'ont pas de projet ils derrière
derrière comprenez bien il paie des
intérêts sur de l'argent qui ne dépasse
pas alors quand une banque
aujourd'hui près de 209 millions c'est
que vous avez une bonne santé financière
de la collectivité
je pense que chaque citoyen comprend ça
aisément qu'on en fasse dans la majorité
on dit que par donc il ya eu un déficit
qui a été aujourd'hui ramené à un peu
plus de 2 millions d'euros
égouttez on était 23 1 millions on est
dans l'usagé du faux déficit permanent
aujourd'hui pour justifier son
incapacité à mettre en oeuvre cet album
de projets 1 la chambre régionale des
comptes a corrigé le présumé difficile
de 2015 de la région en excédent d'un
demi million sous là je ne reviendrai
pas je n'y reviendrai pas d'accord la
chambre régionale des comptes a tranché
il faut intégrer ce résultat
excédentaire dans les comptes
aujourd'hui la situation est encore
assez pathétique puisqu'il donne le
sentiment qu'il ya encore un déficit
mais réduit puisque c'est leur compte de
gestion
c'est leur responsabilité gens répètent
ils sont en fonction depuis le 17
décembre 2015
et donc il n'ya pas de déficit parce que
lorsqu'on regarde le code de bilan
détaillé du du payeur on se rend compte
qu'il ya beaucoup d'argent dans les
caisses d'ailleurs le conte se termine à
+ 36 7 millions d'euros après c'est un
jeu de restes à réaliser bien sûr il
charge les dépenses
ils ne prennent pas en compte les
recettes d'accord et ils manipulent en
mettant en place un faux déficit mais la
traçabilité des os font que ces recettes
vont apparaître à un moment donné je
rappelle simplement qu'ils doivent
pouvoir justifier de la baisse de 200
millions d'euros d'investissements entre
2016 et 2017 parce qu'ils ont voté un
budget 2010 est en réduction de 1
milliard 135 millions alors que en 2016
quand ils arrivent à la cité m
ils ont un budget de près de 1 milliard
315 millions d'euros héritage ch de
chimie de josette malherbe donc beaucoup
d'argent qu'ils ont déjà diminué à près
de 200 millions - donnant
ils doivent pouvoir le justifier comment
la justifier s'il termine avec un
excédent en plus cela prouve qu'ils
n'ont pas de projet parce qu'ils ne
savent pas quoi faire de cet argent
bataille de chiffres on n'en sort pas
entre difficile tu pas de déficit
vous pensez sincèrement que le
martiniquais aujourd'hui et je veux être
je ne veux pas être vulgaire je veux ne
veut pas être non plus triviale mais
est-ce que vous pensez que le
martiniquais on a quelque chose à faire
est ce qu'aujourd'hui se sait ce sont
les préoccupations des martiniquais ça
mais écouter aujourd'hui il ya une
équipe une gouvernance à la tête du pays
ça use mettre en place le projet vous
avez vu vieillir par exemple on est venu
nous dire oui mais faites nous des
propositions mais quand on vous fait des
propositions ils ne les prennent pas en
compte
on a des projets qu'on veut mettre en
place simplement ceux qui ont l'argent
circule les manettes ceux qui ont le
pouvoir
alors ils ne veulent pas de propositions
ils détruisent tout et le mettre en
place
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
opposition constructive on essaie de
faire des propositions on essaie
d'avancer d'exactions concrètes pour que
justement pu sortir de ce marasme et de
cette souffrance dans lequel le pays se
trouve pour faire redémarrer le pays
mais on ne nous entend pas on ne peut
pas aller plus loin sinon que de dire la
vérité aujourd'hui puisque c'est eux qui
dirigent la collectivité territoriale
martinique qui possède le plus gros
budget la martinique avec un milliard
135 millions pour 2017 mais un milliard
près de 400 millions pour 2016 sachant
que le deuxième plus gros budget de la
martinique c'est la cacem avec 160
millions d'euros vous voyez la
différence aujourd'hui de volume
financier a dépassé à injecter à
investir dans le pays parce que si vous
les récolter si vous voulez créer de la
richesse
il faut investir aujourd'hui on est au
point mort de l'investissement dans ce
pays et c'est ce que les martiniquais
attend de sortir du chômage
sortir des difficultés financières avoir
un épanouissement individuel et
collectif pouvoir permettre à ce que nos
enfants aillent au niveau de l'éducation
en toute sécurité quand on voit capot -2
6 me - 6 millions d'euros
d'investissements dans les collèges ou
2016 alors que l'éducation est une
priorité aujourd'hui quand on voit que
des centaines d'entreprises ne sont
toujours pas payés parce que les délais
de paiement sont de plus de 10 mois que
les associations que les personnes qui
touchent l'aide sociale ne sont toujours
pas payés parce qu'ils sont un peu
perdus et qu'ils ont des difficultés en
matière d'organisation
oui le les gens attendent de savoir à
quel moment ils vont pouvoir percevoir à
la fois les entreprises les aides
financières les subventions pour les
associations et les aides sociales pour
les plus démunis qui souffrent
ça c'est important mais aujourd'hui non
seulement le pays est à l'arrêt mais
l'outil n'est pas aujourd'hui
fonctionnel ni opérationnel et ils ne
veulent pas l'avouer il reste dans un
déni et nous devons en sortir
concrètement mais l'outil c'est vous qui
l'avez comment façonner
mais vous allez vous reconnaissez qu'il
ya eu des erreurs
non non non je dis là pas de problème
vous avez vous la recherche une voiture
elle est très belle elle fonctionne elle
un goût aux moddeurs elle est menacée
par l'outil qui n'est pas fonctionnel ce
sont les personnes qui dirigent l'outil
qui ne sont pas opérationnels
comprenez bien ce que je dis le pilote
de la voiture ne fait pas que la voiture
est mauvaise c'est un bon pilote la
voiture qu'elle ce quel que soit le
pilote la voiture elle n'a pas de
problème
l'outil n'est pas discutable ce qui est
discutable c'est le pilote qui conduit
l'outil aujourd'hui qui fera que eh bien
il ya une performance ou bien il est
véritablement un recul significatif
vous allez demander aux préfets de jeter
un oeil sur ce joli clin d'oeil bien sûr
nous avons demandé aux préfets d'agir
pour faire appliquer les corrections de
la chambre régionale des comptes
aujourd'hui ça va faire deux ans nous
avons attendu patiemment que l'excédent
soit intégrée aujourd'hui ils font comme
s'il ne voit rien opaque à houeillès
apavou et et pourtant la chambre
régionale des comptes a donné ses
conclusions ces corrections elles
doivent être appliquées
eh bien nous les ferons appliquer par le
préfet concrètement et nous saisirons
pour que ce faux comptes administratifs
qui a été voté hier ce faux comptes
administratifs qui est différent du
compte de gestion et puissent être
également rétabli parce que aujourd'hui
il y a de l'argent dans les caisses mais
au passage qu'ils menaient tout faire et
puis l'aja tard quand on voit qu'il
termine l'année avec 84 millions d'euros
dans les caisses au 31 décembre 2016
faux pas et venez dit que pagny l'âge la
sphère des affaires des martiniquais
n'appartiennent plus au martin kemp une
tierce personne pour régler les affaires
du martiniquais en trombe et écoutez
c'est pas plus compliqué la résolution
et messieurs et à l'assemblée nationale
l'époque celle ci me l'a présenté quels
sont les deux personnes qui ont voté
contre
jean-philippe ni l'or et alfred marie
jeanne la résolution aimé césaire
vous entendez donc si entre martiniquais
on n'arrive pas simplement par des
désirs de vengeance permanent récurrent
parce que vous entendez dans les
discours ils sont faits hier par le
président du conseil exécutif
on revient sur du passé
et on vient sous des hommes et des
femmes comme si ce ne sont pas des
dirigeants qui ont dirigé comme eux
mêmes à un moment donné de la vie de ce
pays eh bien oui aujourd'hui ils sont
direction la démocratie a parlé mais
comme la démocratie a parlé aussi en
juin 2017
il faut entendre le peuple parler et
surtout faut se mettre au service du
peuple et ne pas chercher à utiliser
l'argent public à d'autres fins a le
cachet pour venir dans un an ou deux
expliqué que finalement on à redresser
le pays a de l'argent alors que l'agent
la hica suivent l'année pour l'année il
a mais pas qu'à dépenser alors que le
pays a besoin considérablement
d'investissement comme sorti qu'on sort
des chiffres il arrive que vous goûtiez
des désorientations comme une menace
etienne moi je me souviens de plénières
où ça se passe bien ou voûté avec la
majorité des dossiers adopté à
l'unanimité et que vous faites également
le même constat que les ressources
s'amenuisent et sur la nécessité aussi
de trouver d'autres sources de
financement
écoutez accord sur ça mais ça fait
quinze ans que les dotations d'état
diminue d'accord on le sait depuis
toujours maintenant il faut y faire face
mais quand vous ne crée pas de richesse
comment voulez vous créer de recettes
nouvelles et pour créer des richesses
vous jamais et booth mais faut investir
donc vous dépassez maintenant pour
récolter il faut que un héros d'agents
publics puissent produire 10 euros je
prends un exemple très simple passage à
steam et arrive à la région le budget de
la région de l'époque 2010 était de 310
millions d'euros mais quand il a quitté
la région
le budget de la région était de 570
millions d'euros ça veut dire qu'il ya
250 millions d'euros de richesses
nouvelles qui ont été injectés et qui
ont été créés ce que sais-je à cette
dynamisation fois les élus eux mêmes qui
sont manque de d'imagination qui ne
peuvent pas créer un nouveau paradigme
qui n'arrivent pas à changer eux mêmes
de logiciels quand je les ai lus les
élus tous bords confondus
mais écoutez vous pas mettre tout le
monde dans le même sac
parce que je pense qu'à des élus qui se
sacrifie pour le pays et même si
peut-être que les autres essaient de
faire des efforts mais aujourd'hui le
système de vengeance qui consiste à dire
que bon c'est pas moi c'est l'autre là
m'a cassé et l'agent et puis mon pack a
dépassé puis ok dit que c'est faute les
messier alors que c'est pas ça du tout
clic à alépé un pays à la question est
une question de projet nous devons
regarder l'avenir en confiance mais
pousse la favorite
et et des projets malheureusement
l'équipe en place n'en a pas donc
effectivement l'argent reste dans les
comptes jeunes et hajar merci bonne
journée aller coûte de nos programmes